You gotta be so much kinder to people when you just thinking shit like that.
It helps you understand how people are like you are on in to just about anybody,
man.
And it's like so easy to have someone in your life and enjoy the idea that there
are asshole and they deserve it.
But if you spend just a speck of time thinking about it,
it's like we really were.
It's sad in a weird way.
It sucks.
We'll just wait until you have kids.
Then it gets really,
really interesting because you start looking at people like they used to be
babies.
That's what happened to me.
I kept a Bobby boy common man.
No,
you do.
I don't.
I like,
yeah,
this is the first place I have said it.
Holy Shit,
Daddy.
She said,
it's okay.
You know you can win when you're in the early months here.
I don't know why,
but like you're scared.
It's such a sacred thing,
you know?
It's a vulnerable thing to talk about.
It makes you feel vulnerable.
It makes you feel nervous and because of that energy or you're worried about
talking.
I fucking love it.
Dude,
it is the most transformative,
like you know,
like you hear,
oh the time to the point where I was like suspicious of it.
Like I was like,
you know,
I don't stand up has done this joke for awhile,
so I think I'm allowed to say it.
Are you not shy?
Not even,
or what,
what's,
what's the rule?
Yeah.
He doesn't do any of the old stuff.
He's got some of my favorite jokes of all time.
Many of them.
But he's got this killer fucking joke about Alva like a pregnant people are like
heroin addicts,
you know?
They're like,
just try it.
You'll love it.
Just try it.
And then,
and then when you do it,
like you know,
you're stuck,
you're trapped.
Which is how I used to think.
But man,
it's like so humbling to realize that all this shit you heard was true in the
sense that you hear people say,
oh no,
it's psychedelic,
it's psychedelic.
Now I,
I always associated that with like when the baby's born,
there must be some serotonin or dopamine that gets released,
not just in the woman.
We know the woman's brain is flooded with oxytocin in a variety of things.
The mother,
the bonding chemicals.
But you know,
I thought,
well,
that are clearly what happened for the father.
Maybe just not in the same level.
So when people say it's Psychedelic,
that must be what they meet.
But now I know,
you know,
the birth is,
hasn't happened yet to it,
but just being in the presence of a person who's growing a life inside of their
belly
and realizing that like the bonding that's happening there and like the sacred
duty is coming up if you being a father and that a soul is coming into this
dimension that is going to be,
um,
completely dependent on you and my wife,
of course,
wanting to keep her safe and then man,
it,
the combination of all these things is so incredibly psychedelic in the most
beautiful way and humbling because it's like,
boy,
oh boy did I fucking tell myself that I had figured out something really smart.
And that was like w reproduction is a trick of the DNA.
And this marriage thing in the baby thing is some kind of vast digital societal
Oregon,
like the appendix.
We don't need to do that.
There's nothing to it.
Obviously I wasn't using that voice,
but like it was such a pretentious fucking pompous,
ridiculous place that I was standing at,
which is to judge,
okay.
People for reproducing,
having,
enjoying the ability to judge because my parents reproduced.
You know what I mean?
So it's so humbling to realize like,
oh,
I was wrong,
but I wasn't just like Kinda wrong.
Like I was deeply,
fundamentally,
completely wrong about this phase of life in this,
uh,
what's the word for it?
This,
um,
well,
I like in Hinduism they call it an Ostrom,
like a monastery.
It's called the Green Hosta.
Ah,
Schrom.
It's like a temple.
It's considered to be like a temple.
The family.
Holy Fuck Man.
It's real.
The rubbers hit the road man.
And it's like,
it's really,
really beautiful though.
Obviously a little scary.
Yeah,
it's love.
It's real love.
And it's love where you know,
you know you're going to be able to love your children unconditionally in a,
in a very strange way that we really have a hard time with other people.
And I think the thing about it is not just that you're bringing a life into this
world which is very psychedelic,
but that your love bond with this kid is so ultimate.
It's so,
it's so intense.
The love that you have for each other to raising the kid together.
There's a thing that happens with,
with,
with people when they are just really deeply connected at a DNA level.
Like this is a little person that is literally come out of nowhere from two
bodies.
It makes you realize how precious life is,
how vulnerable we all are.
And it makes you realize that,
I mean it's such a cliche phrase,
the actual power of love and it's not just the love of this kid or the love of
yourselves,
the two together and the family together and all the other,
you know,
people that you love.
It's a love of all people.
It's the love.
It's just,
it's,
we just really have a hard time loving people.
We have a really hard time trusting that people are going to love us back.
They're not going to get in our way and they're not going to be overly needy or
annoying,
or they're not going to be intrusive or they're not going to tell you what to
do,
which is why people hate their fucking parents telling them what to do.
Oh,
block comes with this bullshit.
Love comes with this nonsense.
Love comes with fucking rules and I have to be annoyed all the time and I have
to wear my suit on Sunday.
Yeah,
fuck love.
Fuck it.
I don't want it.
Right.
Then that carries on.
You develop these,
these shields that you put up for the whole world because of that.
That's one of the most common things that people do when,
uh,
when,
in terms of like our definitions of love,
we define it by the people that were supposed to be the lovers in our lives,
but they're just unconditional kindness and love.
So,
so few people are balanced in the,
the beginning of the relationship.
It's just lust.
And then after awhile you get annoyed with each other and you can't wait to get
free and find somebody else who's going to make you happy.
And they don't make you happy either.
And most of us in the early years of our lives in particular,
we bounce around,
you know,
we try to find a new person that's going to make us happy.
That's right.
And we attract the kind of people that are the most destructive for us.
I mean,
for some strange reason,
we're always looking to be distracted.
Yes.
And when I think when you can learn how to abandon that,
and it's not a learned,
like now I know it's a slow,
gradual process where the instances of continuous occur less frequently,
less and less and less and less frequently to your more and more and more kind.
And then you,
you know,
you get it as good as you can get it on any given day.